[Music]
since it's his Kids Choice Awards I do
want to ask you you know kids across the
country are making such a difference
today and what a big day being a mama
like what does this mean to you just to
watch the youth of our country stand up
boom it's a big question and get that
honestly gets me choked up because I
think this is the generation we've been
waiting for they're the ones who are
gonna get it done and it's just really
inspiring to watch and as a mom knowing
that this is the next well knowing that
these kids have a genuine chance of
making things a little bit better for
when my kids go to school I am eternally
grateful
Kristen Bell also opened up about some
lighter topics at the 2018 Kids Choice
Awards first of all what's going on with
a bathroom indexes podcast studio we're
gonna get a door we just have to figure
out how to do it I think it's gonna have
to be a curtain because it's a triangle
how do you make a triangle door I know
but I think it well listen if anyone can
it's you well it doesn't seem to bother
anyone who actually works in that space
except me and I'm just like such a
hostess that I'm worried that like you
know when people come to the do the
podcast if they have to tinkle they're
gonna be like embarrassed yeah podcasts
are all about letting it all out yes
right he says it's an intimate space I
can't it listen it's his work I can't
argue
[Music]
[Applause]